I hate intros nanatsu no taizai season 2
part 1 side note you could bind part 2
at the end of this video or in the
description below before episode 1 I'll
go over the specials most of it was just
filler soldiers hit the main points
special what really otis goes to speak
with the horn of cirno knows this is
where ban had went in season 1 and was
promised by the goddesses that lin would
be saved if he kills meliodas Billy Otis
tells the goddess to stop lying to his
friends and then destroys the horn a boy
spots the flying creature of reference
at the end of season 1 which is actually
applying arm the presumed dead dreyfus
shows up and he's been following the arm
nothing happens it's special to so we'll
move right along to special 3 the only
thing you need to know about special 3
is that Diego had recovered her
childhood memories of King and they're
both in love with each other but neither
can get a chance to confess been the
last seen the flying arm is actually
Hendrickson's which returns to his
tattered body and briefs him the coffin
of eternal darkness hendrickson
hallucinate scene dreyfus giving him
blood and when he wakes up he is healed
Dreyfus is there with him bearing the
strange black mark on his head joy is
also brought a bandage stained with
Elizabeth's blood now that Hendrickson
has blood from the Apostle with the gods
he can revive the demon clan and special
for King vulture has a premonition of
Camelot being in grave danger and in the
last scene we see Hendrickson performing
the ritual to revive the demon client so
with that out of the way we can get into
episode 1 Reed kick things off with the
sins being awarded medals for restoring
peace to the kingdom bad plans on
leaving before that though and tells
King that he's going to the fairy Kings
forest which was supposed to have been
destroyed when Elaine was killed
naturally this confuses King and it gets
curious so he goes with them during the
award ceremony we were introduced to the
pleiades of the azure sky which is an
order of holy night speed a man that the
sins demonstrate their power before
accepting the awards hawk had gotten a
new earring for Merlin called Baylor's
magical eye which allows him to see the
power levels of the Knights
Joe Gatto tries to fight with meliodas
which isn't exactly a fight because he
just breaks his fingers and then smacks
him ending the fight
we then get a quick rundown of some of
the sins stats from hot we have Mellie
Otis with magic four hundred force nine
seventy spirit 2010 overall 3370 Guth
are sitting at magic 1,300 force 500
spirit 1,300 overall 3,100 do magic 900
for 1870 spirit 480 overall 3250 Merlin
is out here smurfin with magic 3544 70
spirit 1100 overall 4700 as for the holy
night skill thunders 1970 Hauser 1910
and Gideon more 1520 anyways back to the
story the ground suddenly starts to
shake and Mellie Otis can sense that
Dave return jump on over to Hendrickson
with rich will now complete it Dreyfuss
seems to be possessed by a demon called
progerin Roger and tells Hendrickson
that he'll let him live because that's
what Dreyfuss had requested and then we
get a quick look at the 10 commandments
making their debut as the strongest
demons of that answer to the demon king
we have gloxinia daddy Eddie come on
speak let's go uh gallon gray Road troll
esta rosa progerin and finally Zell
juries episode 2 over to Kingdom ban who
were followed by Jericho because she is
thirsty for ban too bad he's a pedo they
arrive at the fairy Kings forest where
King is marked as a traitor by the other
fairies while ban is titled as the new
fairy king ban was given the last seat
from the forest by Elaine before she
passed away so he fulfilled her dying
wish of planting it and regrowing the
forest Elaine's body is also being kept
there because ban is still obsessed with
the reviving her guilt Thunder and the
other two Knights leave to find the
truth behind dreyfuses actions we get
some Girl Talk when Elizabeth confesses
that she loves meliodas to Deanna wall
Deanna confesses that she loves King to
Elizabeth jump back over to king who had
retrieved his best friend hell brooms
helmet after killing him in season 1 now
when he wears 8 he sees Hell berm spirit
which dwells in the helmet we get a
quick side story of goeth her wiping the
memories of zeal and Geetha so that he
could be together with Geetha because he
wants to experience love Darren who
finds out about this and doesn't approve
so they end up getting into a fight II
episode 3 dude who is able to stop go
through and he returns to the memories
that he took from Geetha and her brother
we learned that Gotha is actually a doll
created by
powerful sorcerer and Merlin changes him
back into his doll form
she asks later from dawn roar to look
after him I don't know why because
Slater ends up joining them on their
mission anyways were Merlin teleports of
them to Camelot which is under siege by
a mysterious giant called Albion with an
overall of 5,500 in the face of this new
threat Merlin is forced to return Mele
Otis's sacred treasure lost Bane will
Yodas uses this to clone himself five
times and all of the clones use his full
counter reversing Albion strike and
one-shotting it in the last scene a
different colossal demon weapon shows up
at the forest where ban and King are
episode four king fights with the giant
demon weapon making the other fairies
regret calling him a traitor meanwhile
Ben is attacked by her head because she
doesn't approve of him being labeled as
fairy King she wants to turn van into a
permanent fountain of youth using his
blood to supplement the forest so she
impales him preventing his aid in the
fight King starts losing the fight so
fairies prepare to sacrifice themselves
to buy King time to escape but he
refuses to escape and launches one last
attack his spirit generates immense
power and strikes down the Albion saving
the forest and the fairies while leaving
King unconscious back over to Mele
Otis's group were one of the 10
commandments gallant shows up looking
for a fight in Hawk sees that his
overall is 26,000 Yepez owed by King
drinks bans blood and is healed since
it's mostly found of youth and the
forest damages to repair it as well in
the fight with Galan nobody can stand up
to his power so Merlin tries to distract
him but ends up lying to him this
commandment is truth so when somebody
lies in his presence they are turned to
stone which is what happens to Merlin
morones gets the mark on his head
boosting his overall to 4400 and tries
fighting back with even that not working
he kicks things up a notch where half of
his body is covered in the black
markings like at the fighting festival
in season 1 breaching 10,300 he
struggles against the darkness from
being in this state and still loses two
gallon gallon goes on to kill him later
Merlin stone form and Eno before leaving
gouthru then turns back into his human
form naked and laughs
two up over to yell thunder and the
other two Knights who come across a town
under attack by a red demon so they slay
the demon but that are greeted by a gray
demon this gives the entrance of
Hendrickson who is also trying to stop
the demons II episode six Hendrickson
seems to be back to human and lost his
demon abilities they fight with the gray
demon and when he sees an opening
Hendrickson uses purge which defeats the
demon we then get a flashback 10 years
ago with Hendrickson and Dreyfuss they
go to investigate ruins where the city
data for was destroyed well there
Hendrickson gets possessed by the demon
fraud Rijn who then forced the
cooperation of Dreyfuss once they get
back to the kingdom they framed the
seven deadly sins for the murder of Gil
thunders father's heir Atris fraud ruin
is also the demon that killed
melioidosis one true love Liz
this causes Mellie Otis to lose control
of his emotions and destroy the entire
city of data for nearly killing fraud
rain in the process facts in the sense
where we find out that go thir had
placed memories into Galan that he
killed the sins but in reality they all
survived ruolin transferred her soul to
her sacred treasures so she can still
communicate with them by has no body
they decide that they need to train and
get stronger as well as find the lesson
King returns and is eager to finally
confess to Deanna but when she wakes up
she doesn't know who he is
episode 7 yeah whose memories were
erased by goethe ur as well so he gets a
good smack from King and they rushed to
find ya who who would went off by
herself she's assumed to be going back
to her hometown we get a flashback of
the giant clan sixteen years ago with
some of the Giants dno Matrona and
Dolores the Giants lives revolve around
fighting but Dolores and Eno don't want
to kill do you suggest that they leave
together but Dolores refuses saying that
nobody could accept Giants theater goes
off by herself which is when she meets
Mellie Otis hearing that they will be
accepted by Mellie Otis she goes back to
get Dolores also however Dolores went
out on a mission and was killed by
mountain bandits Pyrrha and Matrona are
employed by the Knights of Leona's to
help bring the bandits to justice
they're betrayed by the Knights emirate
Rona is killed by a poisonous arrow
Danner is framed by the remaining
Knights that survived mature on his
attacks and sentenced to death
meliodas steps in saying that he will
take her under his charge instead saving
her life
episode 8 well trying to return to her
old home Deanna is found and attacked by
gallon and one of the other Commandments
month speed before she is killed Matrona
who turns out to be alive steps in to
save her
three others presents had disappeared so
Merlin suggests changing course to the
sacred land of the Druids east arm this
is where Mele Otis's true power was
hidden by Merlin after taking it from
him and fear that he might lose control
of his emotions again wouldn't they
arrive they are greeted by some new
faces Jenna's honoree and Theo in order
to get his power back Mele Otis has to
endure a trial in the last scene he
wakes up in the past where he is greeted
by Liz episode 9 the trial is Mele ODIs
being forced to relive his peaceful days
with Liz thousands of times over each
time ending in her death and him losing
control he can't be trusted with this
power if he can't control his emotions
so the trial is designed for him to kill
his emotions the others are taken away
to begin their training as well where
they run into Hendrickson and the other
three nights Millie Otis finally decides
he has to let go of the pain from the
death of Liz in order to prevent
something like that from happening again
after realizing this he is finally able
to pass the trial over to ban and
Jericho who are still trying to
resurrect d'Alene Baird rumors of
someone being resurrected in a really
shady town so they go there to
investigate they come across a dying
werefox who supposedly took part in the
resurrection but it was all just a rumor
we then get a flashback of little band
stealing food and being in prison where
he meets as if ago a episode 10 man was
starving and constantly beaten so he
asks Avago to teach him how to steal
which he agrees to and takes him under
his wing then gets caught trying to rob
a mansion and zip hago is about to save
him when he hears that his werefox son
had been found out he takes on his true
form as a where Fox is to get to his son
leaving band to get beaten this reveals
that the dying where Fox is actually
Bands mentor and father figure from all
those years ago his son ends up dying as
he reaches him and he never forgave
himself relieving ban behind Ben reveals
his identity to the werefox and says
that he made the right choice going
after his son and he never harbored any
bad feelings towards him Yepez Oda Levin
after reminiscing on some of the old
times Avago ends up passing away Billy
Otis was training with King
and they get into a fight because King
questions his loyalty after the training
Mellie Otis finally has his power
returned to him who then wants Merlin to
teleport him to the demons camp when he
arrives Galan tries to pick a fight with
him but he can't stand up to the power
of the new-and-improved meliodas
during his visit we also find out that
him and zell juries are actually
brothers millie otis gives them a
warning and as they go to attack him
Merlin teleports him back II episode
well the commandments have to start
recovering their powers if they're gonna
fight again smelly Otis so they spread
out in pairs to eat human souls in towns
and cities everybody finishes up their
training and before they leave we
learned that Melly Otis is so drawn to
Elisabeth because she is actually the
reincarnation of Liz the training did
bear fruit with Gil thunders overall
going up to two thousand three hundred
and thirty while Hauser's goes up to two
thousand three hundred and fifty they're
both pale in comparison to Melly Otis
who's sittin pretty at thirty two
thousand five hundred but all of the
training was actually positive though as
grimore was actually turned into a child
one of the commandments uses a spell to
resurrect the dead who are harboring
strong regrets
Elaine comes back to life but doesn't
seem quite right because she switches to
some ominous attire and that starts
attacking the elves pilgrim tells King
what's going on so he goes up by himself
to stop her and in the last scene Elaine
is reunited with BAM I'm gonna be doing
part two and that'll be in the bottom
left but after I'm finished with it or
you can check out all the nanatsu no
taizai recaps in this playlist here you
can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing I
hate more than intros is outros